public sénat en partenariat avec la ffb
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean christophe cambadélis le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec la fp
avec radio classique avec les échos vous
répondrez à trois grandes questions au
cours de cette émission oui d'abord la
crise de la droite est elle une aubaine
pour vous vous répondrez à jean francis
pécresse ensuite pourquoi la campagne de
benoît hamon inquiétant que très et demi
voire voire 16 d'intentions de vote
selon les sondages pourquoi la campagne
de votre candidat patine vous le dirai à
jérémy marot enfin comment résister à la
tentation macro et oui une tentation
forte chez beaucoup d'élus socialistes
qui vont même désormais jusqu'à lui
offrir leur parrainage question de
mickaël szames s mais d'abord une
question d'actualité
[Musique]
la sofres vient de livrer son baromètre
annuel sur le front national 33 % des
français se disent désormais en accord
avec les idées du fn même si l'image de
ce parti ne s'améliore pas bien au
contraire est-ce que vous êtes d'abord
inquiets ou d'une certaine manière
rassuré par ce sondage on en peut être
rassuré en disant que deux français sur
trois ne veulent pas du front national
mais 33% c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup
c'est mon seul à démonter les idées du
front national les positions du front
national ont pénétré très largement dans
la société française et que ça crée un
climat propice à sa progression
électorale alors ce qui la freine
apparemment même si elle est toujours
très haut on sait bien sûr on en parlera
au cours de cette émission c'est que 58%
des français hélas et 11 points de plus
qu en 2012 jugent que le fn est
dangereux pour la démocratie donc c'est
en fait c'est l'échec de la
dédiabolisation voulue par marine le pen
oui mais ceci ne fait pas pour autant
l'équation électorale car si elle est
qualifiée au second tour celle est au
dessus de 30 parce que je pense qu'elle
est sous-estimée dans les sondages et
que les autres sont en dessous de 20
dans une équation politique très très
difficile et penser que s'il ya un
différentiel de 10 points avec son
suivant elle est sûr d'être élu
je pense que la situation sera difficile
mais d'un certain point de vue le mal le
mal est fait est-ce que vous donc
partager les l'obsession dit on à
l'elysée de françois hollande qui est
justement de rester lui dans la
postérité comme le président qui aura
qui aurait accueilli marine le pen sur
le perron en mai prochain une obsession
je dis ça depuis des mois et des mois
qu'il ya un risque qu'il faut le conjuré
et que le seul moyen de conjurer ce
risque c'est de revenir au débat et non
pas être dans la séquence que nous
vivons en ce moment autour des affaires
d'accord encore un beau quand même sur
la progression dans les intentions de
vote du front national de marine le pen
quelle est la part de responsabilité de
la gauche forcément vous en prenez votre
part car le fait que les couches
populaires comme l'ont dit les français
qui se sentent laissés pour compte bien
se tourner vers marine le pen c'est
aussi le bilan du quinquennat
je pense pas que ce soit le bilan du
quinquennat c'est une grâce du parti
sinon je vais terminer
c'est un grand échec de la part de la
gauche collectivement c'est un échec et
de ne pas avoir pu ou su réduire le
front national parce que je ne crois pas
que ce soit le rôle entre ce n'est pas
la possibilité de la droite c'est à la
gauche de faire ce travail et le n'a pas
réussi à le faire à cause de ses
divisions
parce que son projet progressiste n'est
plus efficace dans le moment présent
je vais je tire un bilan très négatif
que ça appuyer notre d'autres combats
contre le front national a donc ça ça
vous conduire déchirante révision donc
si on je suis je crois qu'il faudra
s'interroger pourquoi tous les courants
progressistes en europe et dans le monde
sont dans l'incapacité de faire face au
national populisme à cette nouvelle
donne
c'est le cas aux états unis mais aussi
on le voit en autriche
on peut leur va le voir dans quelques
jours aux pays-bas ou ville d'heure va
arrivé très largement en tête et on est
encore plus violent lui il a pas de
dédiabolisation il encore plus violent
que marine le pen c'est une nouvelle
donne et nous sommes
d'un certain point de vue à gauche
désarmé face à face à cette nouvelle
pour la suite avec une autre question
que vient poser jean francis pécresse le
directeur de la rédaction radio
classique
bonsoir jean francis bonsoir michel
bonsoir jean christophe cambadélis alors
est ce que la crise à droite qui n'est
peut-être pas fini on en parlera tout à
l'heure est ce que cette crise c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle pour la démocratie ou
est ce que c'est une aubaine pour vous
si mauvaise nouvelle pour la démocratie
parce que cette crise obscurci
totalement la présidentielle on ne peut
pas dialoguer échanger et proposer on
est toujours ramener la preuve monsieur
fillon ces affaires marine le pen ces
affaires oui mais mais on nous interroge
en un peu moins d'ailleurs mais on nous
interroge sur ces questions là donc le
temps que l'on passe à répondre à
stigmatiser à dire que c'est pas bien
il faut changer les choses ou invective
et la droite sur ce sujet on le passe
pas développer nos propres projets
dans son édition de ce soir qui sera en
kiosque demain le canard enchaîné révèle
que françois fillon aurait bénéficié en
2013 d'un prêt sans intérêt de marc
ladreit de lacharrière qui n'auraient
pas été déclarés à la haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
nouvelle affaire fillon qui est en train
de démarrer est ce que vous pensez que
c'est un nouveau scandale
évidemment on est obligé de le faire de
déclarer si vous mentez à la haute
autorité comment on peut vous faire
confiance
après alors j'entends que ce l'avocat de
monsieur fillon dit mais il s'est créé
spontanément aux policiers qu ensemble 8
voilà je veux bien que se rendront
compte que ceux ci allaient être
découvert il est dit ou tient au fait
j'ai
faire un emprunt mais vous voyez bien
tout ça c'est franchement voilà c'est ce
que vous voulez que je vous dise moi les
bras m'en tombent
vous voyez bien le soupçon qu'il ya
derrière cette affaire se presser un
soupçon de favoritisme de trafic
d'influencé en lien avec la légion
d'honneur qui aurait été accordée à marc
ladreit de lacharrière sur
l'intervention de françois fillon
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui vous
qui vous paraît non je veux pas aller
dans ce sens
c'est votre rôle de journaliste de
s'interroger ou d'interroger mais moi je
veux pas alimenter cela car pour
l'instant personne n'a de preuves et moi
je crois très fortement la présomption
d'innocence mais il n'y a pas besoin
d'aller à la contrepartie pour dire que
ceci n'a pas été déclarés voilà points
donc là il ya une faute
lescott est ce que vous avez le
sentiment que dans cette campagne
présidentielle la droite a au fond perdu
le combat moral qui était le sien
c'était le combat de françois fillon
contre françois hollande c'était le
combat aussi de la stature
présidentielle d'une certaine idée de la
fonction je crois que françois fillon
l'a compris et que il a voulu que
l'attitude prennent le pas sur les
turpitudes que l'attitude de soi celui
de l'homme qui fait face aux événements
et que ceux ci permettent de mettre de
côté les turpitudes mais enfin les
turpitudes sont là et c'est un problème
qui est posé à l'ensemble de la société
politique française et qui me démontre
quand même une très grande crise dans
laquelle nous sommes
comment est-ce que vous jugez françois
fillon aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'il vous
inspire
et qu'est-ce que vous inspirent les
images de ce rassemblement dimanche au
trocadéro que certains observateurs
certains observateurs ont qualifié de
trump vient presque populiste au point
de départ quand ceux ci a été lancé
c'était la guerre des pouvoirs c'est à
dire le pouvoir politique contre le
pouvoir judiciaire
c'était face à l'arrivée ça a été un peu
changé parce que quand on est candidat à
l'élection présidentielle c'est
difficile d'être dans cette guerre de
pouvoir mais sain dit quelque chose
c'est que la droite elle existe en
france à tous ceux qui pensaient qu'elle
avait disparu elle existe elle est là
une force une représentation et et que
cette droite là elle ne veut pas de la
gauche sous toutes ses formes
mais allons plus loin parce que s'il ne
veut pas de la gauche sur toutes ses
formes
moi je suis très inquiet d'un deuxième
tour entre marine le pen et par exemple
emmanuel macron ou benoît hamon je ne
sais pas ce que la ferme à droite et
vous attendez quoi des éclaircissements
des précisions du candidat fillon par
exemple demander quoi je lui demande par
exemple de nous dire au cas
d'élimination en train de tout si il
appellerait à voter pour un candidat
républicain
je vais pas personnifiée est ce qu'il le
ferait je n'en suis pas certain vous
avez un doute aujourd'hui vous avez à
gérer avec bien d'autres parce que cette
base elle est chauffée à blanc elle est
là présente en disant on ne va pas nous
voler la victoire
donc s'il n'est pas au second tour sa
victoire aura été volé ces poissons
réflexe mais c'est pour ça que je dis on
se rend pas compte dont on dit waow
toute façon il ya le plafond de verre
etc
pour marine le pen mais on se rend pas
compte de ce que il est en train de
s'installer
vous n'êtes pas sûr que là ce soir si
françois fillon est éliminé du deuxième
tour il appellera à voter emmanuel
macron benoît hamon benoît hamon bon non
mais parce c'est pas sur le lit ni
séquelles que c'est quand même une
théorie qui existe à voir c'est à voir
eh oui et d'abord le lot candidats qui
après l'électorat deux jours après
trocadéro il semble que la droite essaie
quand même de se remettre en ordre de
bataille que même des jupes et it essaie
maintenant de rejoindre les rangs de
françois fillon après les avoir quittés
est ce que pour vous la droite
est-ce qu'elle redevient une menace elle
n'a jamais cessé de l'être car là on
avait vu
des électeurs se dérober dans les
sondages parce que maintenant on fait la
politique qu'avait à partir des sondages
mais il n'était pas anormal que des
électeurs de droite aient été choquées
ce que par les révélations qui ont été
faites autour de monsieur fusion alors
maintenant est-ce qu'ils vont revenir
n'en savons rien est-ce qu'ils estiment
que c'est définitivement terminé
nous en savons rien est ce que monsieur
fillon va accentuer sa radicalisation
contre les pouvoirs contre les élites va
tromper lisez ce sa campagne
nous en savons rien donc c'est un peu
tôt pour le dire qu'est ce que va
demander lui dei en contrepartie
mais vous voyez bien que ce paysage ou
un jour on dit c'est fini je m'en vais
je peux plus être dans la campagne
et puis le lendemain on revient on
s'assoit la bonne table
monsieur larcher s'est trouvé ça
franchement extraordinaire devant le le
siège de campagne annonçant que le
bureau politique pas le commis pas le
comité politique il a dit le bureau
politique
le bureau politique avait décidé à
l'unanimité avec des gens qui avaient
condamné le candidat bon tout ça c'est
terrible pour la démocratie
merci jean francis la deuxième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant avec
jérémie moreau de l' agence
france-presse qui vient vous poser sa
question
l'épreuve de vérité avec l'iphone
jérémy bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
cambadélis alors on est à 40 jours après
41 jours après la désignation d'un de
benoît hamon dans la primaire
on a 47 jours du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle et pourtant la
campagne de votre candidat a du mal à
décoller alors comment vous l'expliquez
on a vu qu'il y avait des sondages qui
montraient que benoît hamon plafonné 13
14%
quel est votre diagnostic et qu'elle
remette vous voulez apporter au chemin
de votre candidat écoutez nous sommes
dans la plaine nous allons aborder les
premiers lacets de l'alpe d'huez
donc vous savez tous si vous êtes des
amateurs du tour de france que ce n'est
pas dans la plaine que l'on fait le trou
mais dans les montées il ya un certain
nombre d'éléments devant nous je pense
tout simplement que benoît hamon est
passé de 6 % dans les sondages à 16%
pour 13% fera entre les deux qu'il a
fait un saut considérable qu'il a dû le
stabiliser et que maintenant ils
rentrent dans le coeur de sa campagne
mais c'est difficile c'est difficile
pourquoi parce qu'il s'est fait rare non
c'est pas parce qu'il a fait des erreurs
c'est difficile parce que alors là on va
passer au football il peut pas installer
il ne peut pas installer son jeu il peut
pas installer son jeu à chaque fois
qu'il fait une proposition
ils discutent ils proposent ballon on
est dans les affaires donc c'est
difficile de l'entendre et c'est une
question qui est posée d'ailleurs à jean
luc mélenchon au 6 mai mais si c'est
difficile de l'entendre aujourd'hui il
ya des candidats qui ne disent
strictement rien dans le même temps
emmanuel manichon a pu président appelle
un programme
dans le même temps amène un accroc a pu
présenter son programme présenterait le
chiffrage de son probable il a été
audibles sur ces propositions mais il va
le faire avec un petit livre manifeste
dans les jours qui viennent
et peut-être que c'est bien vu parce que
emmanuel macron a présenté son programme
dans un moment de paroxysmes hic de
polémique autour de fillon ça a été
tellement vu mais peut-être qu'ils
voulaient pas que ce soit trop vu et la
benoué hamon va pouvoir le faire au vu
et au su de tout le monde donc il est
encore temps pour vous de revenir sur le
fond de reparler des problématiques qui
finalement 20 tasses et les français
je pense que c'est parce que les
français commencent étaient exaspérés du
fait qu'on ne parle pas d'eux et qu'on
ne parle pas de la france donc le
candidat qui va commencer à en parler
sérieusement va à mon avis engranger les
points
dans l'autre question c'est est ce que
tout le monde est en ordre de marche
derrière le candidat socialiste est ce
qu'au sein de la famille socialiste tout
le monde est derrière lui ben non il y à
des contestations des interrogations des
propositions des inflexions il y a comme
toujours chez les socialistes le fait
qu'on veut l'emporter que l'on ait de
nombreux a suggéré bon moi je dis à tout
le monde
garder ses nerfs que la campagne et
priait présidentielle évidemment elle
est à la fois présidentiel et
législatifs ont rien oublié dans notre
dispositif que ce n'est pas encore
terminé
donc il faut se concentrer faire des
propositions aux candidats
ça me semble utile chercher à le
déstabiliser
ça me semble inutile qui cherchent à le
déstabiliser sa personne à cette étape
pour la personne à cette étape
mais au jeu j'entends bien le brouhaha
ou ceux qui nous ont très vite à
déstabiliser ce sont de nombreux élus du
parti socialiste par la campagne qu'il a
menée et par les choix non a dit qu on
entend par exemple je voyais monsieur
icon r le ministre des sports dire mais
quand est ce qu'on va avoir des messages
d'amour de notre candidat oh ça on peut
entonner une formule des messages
d'amour
mais bon je veux dire il est évident je
crois que le candidat là l'a
parfaitement compris dieu il faut
maintenant être le candidat du moins
c'est mon souhait est que benoît hamon
soit le candidat de toutes les gauches
et de tous les écologistes c'est un
moment important il doit être en
capacité de rassembler toutes les
gauches et tous les jeux revient sur ces
messages d'amour il doit attendre
davantage la main sur certaines parties
de sa famille il doit tendre la main à
tout le monde
c'est un coeur tendre la main et que ça
veut dire quoi il faut qu'ils
rassemblent faut qu'ils ouvrent les bras
plutôt qui tendent la main il a fixé un
cap se drape a été adoubé par la
primaire maintenant il faut que tout le
monde soit rassemblé c'est mal à soi lui
pour l'instant life ok qu'est ce qu'ils
doivent faire
on sait pas un voeu pieux il ay là il a
rassemblé dans son équipe de campagne il
a ouvert à des responsables qui n'était
pas avec lui dans la primaire mais il
faut que il parle à tout le monde c'est
très très important
on a vu que benoît hamon était à
marseille aujourd'hui demain ce sera
jean luc mélenchon a marseille il ce
suivisme arc un petit peu à la culotte
est ce que ces deux là incarnent des
positions irréconciliables à gauche
elles sont là les gauches
irréconciliables
ou encore on peut espérer un accord au
bout du chemin moi je suis assez sévère
avec jean luc mélenchon car si il avait
fait un accord avec benoît hamon
aujourd'hui la gauche serait en tête
dans les sondages
donc évidemment il a le droit de se
maintenir mais il n'a pas de raison de
le faire moi je ne suis pas d'accord
avec benoît hamon par exemple sur la loi
travail mais lui et mélenchon ils sont
d'accord
alors pourquoi prendre le risque de
faire perdre cette gauche là par exemple
porte un trait une très grande
responsabilité d'autant que en face à
une droite qui est extrêmement dur et
puis il ya l extrême droite possible
donc moi je suis très sévère avec lui
sur ce sujet merci jérémy aller dernière
partie de l'épreuve de vérité c'est
maintenant michael szames s de public
sénat qui nous rejoint
[Musique]
bonsoir michael au sens michel bonsoir
monsieur comme à dellys en soi moi je
voudrais savoir tout simplement si vous
allez résister à la tentation des
manuels macro gestion plus en plus
nombreux et mais plutôt envie d'y aller
qui certains de vos amis du parti
socialiste et d'autres des ministres
même phrase je dis à tout le monde
gardez votre sang froid les gens qui
vous écoutent garder votre sang froid au
dos on verra jeudi garder votre sang
froid
aujourd'hui nous avons une primaire qui
a désigné un candidat
je suppose qu'ils ancienneté un autre
qui se poseraient pas cette question et
je pense que il faut prendre le temps
que la campagne s'installe les chiffres
parlent peut-être de même parce qu'un
petit c'est aussi de l'arithmétique
voyez un sondage et l'ap qui est paru ce
soir au premier tour emmanuel macron
talonne vraiment marine le pen 26 pour
moi il n'est pas une 25 et demi pour
emmanuel macron est-ce que c'est pas lui
qui est devenu le vote utile pour barrer
la route au front national comme vous
appelez de vos voeux et la cse ces
sondeurs qui ont annoncé pendant toute
la campagne de la droite que juppé
allait gagner pendant toute la campagne
de la gauche que montebourg était en
tête c'est de la soul avons parlé un bon
bah je les crois que maria l'ifop
également qu'il le dise ça ils disent
pas tout à fait la même chose
1 mais je pense que j'ai un reproche à
faire aux sondeurs c'est qu'ils tirent
leurs sondages pour faire une reprise
dans les trois points qui l'ont de deux
possibilités tire vers le haut pour que
ça permette de dire ben voilà
mais ça permet de faire des plateaux je
vous entends bien vous êtes en train de
dire qu emmanuel macron c'est l'homme
des sondeurs l'ange du pot ça je dis
dieu les sondes les sondeurs sont
suffisamment habile pour créer des
fausses nouvelles
des nouvelles sur gré des nouvelles et
on déplore ce sont des auteurs de cette
news ce sont les marges d'erreur
évidemment évident
oui et on le verra on le verra ça ouais
j'en suis sûr et fait que news des de l
avait d autres instituts et met donc si
vous attendiez emmanuel macron ne serai
pas le candidat qui pourrait faire
barrage au front national parce que
c'est ça la vraie question
non mais il a glissé ou par l'est d'el
arabi non mais moi je ressors mes côtés
je prends les problèmes les uns après
les autres
ok d'abord qui doit être au second tour
est-ce que c'est notre candidat ou un
autre candidat a priori c'est plutôt
notre candidat deuxièmement peut-il
notre candidat faire face à marine le
pen s'il est au second tour sera t elle
au second tour on n'en sait strictement
rien parce qu on a fait on a installé le
fait qu'il était obligatoirement se
monte sur la dette
la grande les sondeurs ça peut être la
grande information au soir des élections
la grande nouvelle elle y est pas bon et
donc on aura construit tout un système
par rapport à ça cependant ça avance et
qu'elle y sera mais bon c'est quand même
un élément à avoir en tête
après est ce que on peut créer un combat
une dynamique par rapport à marine le
pen moi j'ai tendance à penser que pour
battre marine le pen il faut un 10-1 une
dynamique populaire et que l'on ne peut
pas là bras la battre simplement par le
people par une personnalité il faut un
ensemble et les propositions qui
mobilise le peuple parce que j'ai peur
que tout le monde ne se retrouve pas
sinon donc emmanuel macron mais pas cet
ensemble cet ensemble à cette étape pour
l'instant on n'a pas encore engagé la
totalité du débat est ce qui vous arrive
d'avoir des hésitations
moi je n'hésite pas généralement
politique
oui je veux en venir et pas trop
compliqué pour ceux qui n'ont peut-être
pas suivi claude bartolone qui est quand
même le président de l'assemblée
nationale dit aujourd'hui hésité entre
benoît hamon emmanuel macron vous l'avez
compris vous avez
walker en lisant ça qu'est ce qui fait
enrager pas lui un haut-le-coeur je sais
que claude bartolone et oui oui c'est un
ami mais claude bartolone et tarabuster
si je puis dire par la montée du front
national on reverrait d'autres parler de
lui s'il hésite c'est pas qu'il n'a pas
dit ce soir dans le monde que ils
choisissent emmanuel macron il il
regarde
il dit d'ailleurs dans le même interview
on n'a pas titré ça là dessus que
évidemment benoît hamon est légitime
puisqu'il a gagné la primaire mais bon
là il gagne assez enfin écoutés mais
quel message message du président de
l'assemblée nationale
patron des députés socialistes également
qui dit aujourd'hui qu'il hésite c'est
un seuil et c'est le patron émir
l'assemblée la cie de la pente et à jal
qui ne se représente pas donc il a une
certaine liberté accord donc il dit moi
je suis pas dans les instants je suis
candidat à rien pour la suite et jeudi
mais le bon alors lequel des deux peut
être le plus efficace déjà éliminés à
droite et bien le diable les deux peut
être le plus et le plus efficace pour
combattre le fond achat je préférerais
qu'ils disent
benoît hamon est évidemment puisque
c'est le candidat qui est sorti de la
primaire mais moi je comprends aussi ses
hésitations ses réflexions ses
supputations mais je dis que ce n'est
pas en
en tournant autour de cela que l'on fera
la campagne de benoît hamon parce que si
on tourne autour de moi
si on tourne si on fait ça on l'a
prévenu mon nom j'ai passé contre son
camp claude bartolone n'a jamais tirer
contre son camp mais il dit tout haut à
l'occasion d'un interview plutôt sur
l'assemblée nationale que bombard en ce
moment et son coeur balance
ouais non ils s'interrogent il est plus
sage en commun t10 ya des secrétaires
d'état qui sont prononcés encore ce
matin sur une radio des ministres et a
dit moi je vienne mais elle s'interroge
également sur la campagne devenu
amoureux qui dit aussi s'interroger sur
l'avenir
il ya des ministres aussi qui pourrait
rejoindre emmanuel macron c'est la fuite
c'est une sorte de fuite en avant
écoutez je crois que ce n'est pas un bon
calcul
parce que pour moi le parti socialiste
ne doit être ni le partenaire junior de
macro ni le partenaire junior le
mélenchon le parti socialiste doit être
incontournable dans la victoire comme
dans la défaite
et il ne faut pas penser court terme il
faut s'interroger et évidemment sur
comment faire pour combattre le front
national et le bat alors lors des
élections présidentielles est ce qu'il
est il faut qu'on sait à quoi ils
pensent à leur carrière et leur avenir
non c'est pas ça c'est que court terme
c'est à dire non à la gaga le problème
du front national évidemment je dis je
dis si on casse le parti socialiste il
faut pas penser que le parti socialiste
en forme aux génisses latine donc il
faut avoir du sang-froid et de la
responsabilité parce que j'estime que le
parti socialiste va être totalement
nécessaire dans la période qui s'ouvre
de la présidentielle et au delà
totalement nécessaire à notre démocratie
et il vaut mieux qu'il soit
incontournable dans la victoire et dans
la défaite que cassé en plusieurs
morceaux et donc incapable de peser sur
les événements et ce ne sont pas des
hommes qui vont peser sur les événements
c'est le président évidemment mais la
majorité parlementaire par les partis
politiques au sens quand même qu'il ya
aujourd'hui une droite fracturée ne
bouge pas loin non plus
vous qui avait théorisé sur les
tripartisme et c'est dans un bâtiment
mairie soit mais l'explosion du
tripartisme mais à partir du moment où
vous aviez le tripartisme et que le
bipartisme a explosé il n'était pas
anormal que on arrive à l'émiettement
alors vous avez parlé des législatives
vous avez adressé des courriers à des
élus qui parrainerait ou qui parraine
emmanuel macron courriers sont arrivés
mais peut-être même eu des réponses je
viens de recevoir par mail la réponse de
françois patriat l'un des courriers ou
lui avait adressées vous dites
simplement que
ils ne pourront plus se réclamer du ps
qu'est ce qu'on leur dit exactement à
leur manque dans ce courrier j'en avais
un tracé convient d'abord je bats ceux
qui ont signé de combien les
parlementaires conçu une petite dizaine
une dizaine attendait leur parrainage
arena est mal macron parce que je le
redis c'est qu'ils connaissent la
plupart d'entre eux ce sont des
camarades qui eux connaissent les
statuts du parti socialiste
ils sont pas ignorants donc je leur dis
ben voila tu connais les statuts tu t'es
mis dans la situation de contrevenir à
nos statuts donc tu peux plus
représenter le parti socialiste et du
coup est ce que c'est est ce que c'est
une sanction pour vous souccar à ne plus
représenter le parti socialiste c'est
une sanction est une sanction plus
sévère a quand même bas pour ceux qui
sont candidats aux législatives c'est
assez compliqué moi je vous rappelle
qu'il ya peu de temps vous parliez même
d'exclure non j'ai jamais dit l'exclure
vous savez je fais très attention à ce
que j'aime et je dis dans ce domaine
vous savez je n'ai pas exclu les
frondeurs qui étaient favorables au
dépôt d'une motion de censure contre
leur propre gouvernement et qui partait
de participer à des manifestations
manifestation excusez moi assez violente
contre le gouvernement j'ai dit que la
question de leur appartenance au groupe
socialiste au parti socialiste serait
posée si cette motion était déposée
jeudi de la même façon que je ne sont
pas les reins et les coeurs et les états
d'âme des uns et des autres mais que si
on part elle qu'elle tient un petit un
adversaire de notre candidat c'est la
même chose
donc à chaque fois je fixe des limites
tout en comprenant les interrogations
les réflexions parce que moi je ne suis
pas un et curateurs je suis un
rassembleur et je comprends qu'on puisse
s'interroger mais je dis à tout le monde
il faut se rassembler et ce soir donc tu
auras croyez que je vais recevoir le
sénateur parti socialiste ou pas va nous
le dire
françois patriat dit vous faites preuve
d'abus de faiblesse
c'est un argument vieux comme le monde
évidemment je serai très fort
six mois au parti socialiste j'avais dit
eh bien écoutez les gars vous soutenez
emmanuel macron bravo mais si c'est
enfin c'est un résident c'est un
raisonnement on va dire assez faible
merci à vous merci michael on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine est notre
invité sera gérard larcher le président
du sénat qui est donc derrière françois
fillon
[Musique]
vous rendez vous avec public sénat
je suis une passe et chance de présenter
première femme à se présenter à la
candidature suprême comme on dit oui
fallait oser le faire et je les fais
d'ailleurs en m'adressant à toutes les
femmes pas seulement celle de la classe
ouvrière qu'elle qu'elle a ma gueule
qu'on puisse me faire un traitement
particulier parce que je suis une femme
c'est une injure c'est une infamie pour
moi mes collègues étaient absolument
fasciné j'ai été tout émoustillé
personne n'a imaginé de dire le général
de gaulle ce quasi aux gens qu aux gens
de la vie une manière de parler que les
femmes souvent politique n'est pas la
même il y avait le côté mère protectrice
on a beaucoup de mal à considérer qu'une
femme qui entre en politique
le fait de son propre chef d'un côté ils
prétendent être heureux de voir des
femmes se présente t elle après sa
terrible il veut côté sont pas forcément
prêts à voter pour elle un jour je serai
présidente
demain à 17 heures sur public sénat
[Musique]
public sénat
au coeur du débat
[Musique]